mommy how was Nebraska it was
[Music]
um the
usual Mr bracket can you tell us what
happened that night at the hotel it was
our anniversary so we wanted to go out I
won't be me you won't be you just two
strangers meeting in a
bar tomorrow
night I'm Jack Alice do you and your
wife role play often what exactly is
this about do you know this man no Jack
Bob Bob Jack pleasure he just talked for
5 minutes to all the victims of her
charms and then he
left the one and only hey where are you
I'll be right
back the wife's real name is Anna Peller
wanted for contract killings across
several
continents
I'm
sorry
what they told me what you are my wife
is an
assassin this is a lot you kill people
it's over I never wanted to lie to you I
just want a normal life that I have a
family to protect you're my wife I am
coming to help you do not come here do
you hear me do not come
here
I love you and I love our family we can
get through this we are concerned about
your wife and the safety of your
family she kills me this one I told you
I need out I'll bring the whole world
down on your
[Music]
heads I love you I have to go to work
now though
okay never met a girl me
before killing is bad like unacceptably
bad I know I know I'm done done I
[Music]
swear